[Music]
robots often conjure images of
clunky pieces of metal a new technology
breaks that mold
building robots from a spray researchers
set the robots in motion by using the
sprays material properties
particles of gluten and polyvinyl
alcohol combined with water molecules to
create a sticky paste
that can hold bits of iron making the
paste magnetic
hence its name m spray these magnetic
skins
helped transform inadequate objects like
origami paper
cotton thread and plastic pipe into
rigid
insect scale machines some crawled
others rolled and one swam as magnetic
fields
acted upon them the researchers then
tested these miller robots
in simulated biomedical procedures they
steered a catheter robot through narrow
blood vessels
they also inserted robotic drug capsules
into living and non-living rabbit
stomachs and used oscillating magnets to
make them disintegrate on command
releasing drugs into the rabbit's
digestive system
the researchers say their spray-on
technique improves on one size
fits all millirobot design offering a
way
to custom tailor the shapes of many
machines
the next step will be to apply the spray
to other materials
and test them in new settings when
working at a millimeter scale
inching along can make a big difference